we are on Roger and Rachel are here
coffee and commerce thank you for
everybody who's tuning in live across
Facebook YouTube Twitter and obviously
everybody's listening to the podcast
which was the first intent but then we
just decided to go live with it because
we could get the audience involved
Rodger Rachel thank you so much for
being on how's your family how's
everybody how are you guys dealing with
this before we get into it we are we're
we're really were very well like my
parents you know my family's all over
the country I mean some in Florida some
in New York everybody you think God is
healthy um I think you know it's one of
those things we find ourselves like
we're about to complain we kind of
stopped ourselves you get the
perspective real fast correct and you
just say this is great we're grateful
we're healthy this is all and there's
worse places to lock down than yes for
sure
Rachel's fixing Rogers hair for
everybody listening because there's
amazing by the way it's one of the stars
of this show so yes that hair
because I know myrtles my hair but it's
yeah sorry let's get right into it for
you know obviously for everybody who's
listening watching we launched painter
commerce this week something I've been
working on for a long time for anybody
just catching up I've been in the wine
e-commerce business since 1996 so very
old school and we're really excited
about this we decided to do some content
to to launch the kind of initiative and
its really turned into a great show
we've got incredible guests and these
two are a great addition that I think
will bring a lot of values so you know
obviously the two of you have a lot in
your careers and I know quite a bit of
it but why don't we why don't within the
context of commerce and e-commerce why
don't you give the audience a little bit
of the origin story what you do and how
you got there let's let's let you take
the floor for a little bit and paint a
little bit of picture and it will well
Jam on it
sure I know he does well
Gary's similar to you I've sort of
old-school media grew up in the email
business Webby Awards all that stuff I
know you know rotten and Noble that
whole crew so and from New York so I had
a media
you know I had a medium company Rachel I
started a media company I'll take a step
back put a TV show on Bravo okay and I
was sort of in this techy world a little
likeyou at that point again I had a
totally different company and what I
realized was two things a all these
people should have this TV show on Bravo
but like Bravo on that platform right
and then Ashton Kutcher
had her go and sign up for Twitter and
she signed up for Twitter and they owned
that platform and I said Rach this is
kind of silly all these people love you
and we don't even have to get in touch
with them we want to sell them something
one day and from that conversation we
said well how can we the first step was
how do we know who these people are
before we can sell them anything so our
first step was yeah you know I think the
big the big difference is you know
between us and maybe other people other
will call it talent is we're in for the
long game we're in for equity value
we're not really in we don't look at
Rachel Rachel
we don't look at her as like providing
services if you were we look at like
we're building a brand in a business
that we sell one day you weren't you
were business people I mean it's kind of
its kind of like I came from a little
bit of a different world to my notoriety
but I'm I was a businessman and then
social created awareness to your point I
knew that from day one even when you
guys kind of hit that you know you got
you guys were real things you're not
acting you're in business you're you're
do you were doing real things it's
actually made the show really hard
because we actually had a real business
we actually had a real relationship time
so it's very actually one of the main
difficulties with actually doing those
types of shows or any reality show is
you know there is reality and there's
not reality and if you're trying to
build a real business and be credible
and respectfully it's very hard to do
both but anyway from that point do you
want to add something no no I just want
to say that you know Roger came from you
busting banking and media and all of
that and and what he's trying to say is
really you know when all of these
amazing women were you know
me on the street or contacting me on
Twitter or whatever it was I wish I
could be styled by you what should I
wear for this you know all of these
things and and Roger basically was like
there has to be a way that you can talk
to these women more women and provide
them with the service that you're
providing you know Cameron yeah yeah
right you can scale you ranks right yeah
you can your one-on-one with Cameron but
there's a hundred fifty thousand women
that have the means to be able to afford
you we need to find that right balance
between the scalability value prop and
and that makes a ton of sense correct
and the truth is is that the intention
really for me it's so funny because I
think that the irony of the Rachel's old
project was I think there was this idea
of what fashion people were or stylists
were and for me I think the thing you
know people are is like how you
different why are you different why were
you able to build a brand or whatever
and I one of the things I would say is
like I cared so much and I genuinely
didn't want to talk to one woman I
genuinely wanted to help as many women
as possible be you know less scared of
getting dressed every day and you know
whatever it is their lifestyle my
mission was always your ambition was
bigger honestly but and by the way
there's nothing wrong with the ambition
of hey I want you know especially you
know especially when you're in a small
town one day I want to go to LA or New
York I want to dress 12 incredible
people live in that scene be a list and
that's a great life - it's just that for
you your ambition was greater yes I want
to reach as many women as I can around
the world right here and then that
really led to the genesis of Liz Earle
report we said gee how do we because
again before before this business I also
had a database email marketing business
before can spam so I understand you know
that you know it's really about data
it's about being able to reach people's
hope once are sure we created how do we
get a lot of people to give us their
email address because at this point
email we figure it was like a cell phone
number yeah it it's still Rajan you know
the killer app I mean email is still a
monster it may not be as sexy but it's
still early
we're very big you know we're very big
game about people but anyway um so we
said hey how do we figure this out how
do we get people's email addresses
Franklin what do we what do we do you
know we were this was almost I don't
want to say he's kind of old before
venture capital like like it wasn't
really at 12 years ago we're the only
people just crazy don't like an idea for
media business let me let me put this in
real life terms I invested in tumblers
be round not at seed not it's a round in
it's B round at a 14 million dollar
valuation yeah now people have ideas
that are 20 year old kids are getting 14
million if the right to angels come in
right yes so for us not anymore tech
we've always been about making a
business so for me it's not about like
it's not like the greater fool theory I
guess is what it is what I'm trying to
say and so we just said hey let's just
do an email newsletter owners about hey
this is an inspirational look and this
how you get to look for less and that's
it so we just started a media company
called those don't report I remember
fighting a lot with her when we named
that I didn't want to call the Zuri poor
cuz I didn't want her naming it at all
because I figured there's gonna be hard
to sell it one day because would they
call it anything call it like bashing
tomorrow luckily though is like a great
kind of like you know Vaynerchuk report
might have been a more problem but so is
perfect like it works because it's like
we compromised it we call it Rachel's or
report we made it though certainly we
compromised and again being how do your
compromises go beautifully a nice or
evil and awesomely bombastic I would say
never evil eye I would say never I mean
listen I I don't know that the age range
which people that are watching this but
compare us mostly to Lucy and Ricky I
would say that is our our best
comparison um we bicker but we are
recovery rate it's about a minute
what if that's that's humongous yeah
no it's really like because both of you
both of you or one of you is wildly
uncomfortable with tension in the air I
don't like tension he's much more tense
I'm Way patient he's way not
like I so wait are you saying you're the
angel and make it better every time yeah
kinda yeah because like my mom and dad
have the same exact relationship my mom
literally my mother is an angel she just
makes it better every time it I just try
and make it better because I'm like to
take a breath let's figure it out and
you know this is amazing ideas it's like
we were just we are so different it is
hard to be in a family business to begin
with when it's around a human that's in
the business that you're talking about I
mean it's impossibly difficult right
it's really interesting because you know
people don't really understand like I'm
almost like talent management right
because it's some whole like do things
like and protect her like as an agent
would right you know because we manage
ultimately manage Rachael Ray does
Laurie the person and coach she's my
business partner and she's my wife I'm
like yeah it says it was a lot of roll
in and out of these roles very quickly
but we listen we've been together almost
30 years so I think we got this but big
piece is that the ideas I know very well
when he is a great idea and what I do is
just say okay let's talk about it and
then you know listen I think Fighting's
never a good way to do things so he'll
just like kind of learn something out
and I think bickering bickering - like -
is a really nice word they're the reason
bickering exists as a word is because
not everything is actually a fight it
may be just a grammar and Torah yeah I
love that
I'm sorry coverage no I'm saying our
team very much knows because like what a
new person comes in they'll be like are
they fighting and then the people have
been with us forever girl good thing
that's love they're loving yes real
quick just complete left ball your left
field because that's how I like to roll
ecommerce what do you like to buy direct
from brand or any brands lately that
have caught your attention things that
you like to buy yeah either one of you
well I honest I'm more of super good
news - I know what he's gonna say for
his answer but I can't wait yeah god
honestly like I am definitely I go to a
place where it's um multi
like I love net I left not a Forte and I
love because I know that whatever I want
will be there well I see I said you like
the cut you like the curating of more so
that I'm going here for my deodorant
here for my fruit here for this yeah
you're not you're not gonna love this
answer but basically for what I want to
buy and purchase like for myself in like
beauty or fashion it's like another part
a or fart facts or something you're
gonna love this
motorist you know Lois Rachel I actually
love that answer I have zero emotion to
people doing anything I'm far more
interested in what people actually do
okay so then so I would say for that
it's Moda mode operandi and the like
because I know that I know the people
behind them and I know that what I want
I can get there right but then separate
of that everything else like for the
house and everything else like food but
Lola Amazon everything how do you do
that or do it like you know obviously
like cuz you like it love it she is like
I'm a control freak and I don't want
anything
she's like a competitive shopper she
like makes cards she's like looks like
kind of like it she likes the process
yeah like if like Pinterest should have
been like Pinterest for bonynge and then
it would have been awesome
you don't I mean like because there
would have been like then you buy it so
how I've been in my business um
everyone's like you must have like the
biggest team in the world and I was
always like God when my team was too big
that made me anxious because it means
I'm I'm happy for you I totally
understand how about for you it's so
funny because I literally run I guess an
e-commerce company and I almost buy
nothing on the Internet it's really I
like you ready for this
I'm sorry to interrupt I my to business
in my life have been social media and
wine and I cuz I know this cuz I know
who I was at 18 I didn't even I would
have never drank alcohol and I would be
a human being that would not put out
content on these platforms if I wasn't
mean the business literally I put out no
personal content on the Internet I would
live and I literally don't drink
anything but
and I would have never fallen in love
with it and would have never drank it
had I not grown up in it literally the
two things I've done in my entire career
I would not do but you know what I
thought funny but you know what's wrong
but it's interesting cuz I don't really
the only thing I buy she's gonna laugh
at me the only thing I really bought I
like Tommy John underwear and I think
they do a really good job too actually
I'm sorry and you know I recently by the
way this goes to show you interestingly
she looks good in it like that's a good
cut for him he's never been in better
show Rodge Rodge but the reason why I'm
saying this is we're doing my Commerce
is it's very interesting I'm already
customer I've been a customer for a year
or two I never thought about buying
women's underwear right because I'm a
guy and then I then I see on TV I don't
know if you've seen those TV as late at
least like 25% off site-wide and they
show a woman there and I'm like I like
them they're Coco I'm like ehh what kind
of thing ever I was doing 45 different
things and he's following me with his
and they have three different three
different fabric types so I guess I like
the internet for shopping for more
information Gary how does that sound I
like you so you do like doing the
research and then you'll go physical
which was really what a lot of people
did for a long time I mean like you know
it you know it's really really
fascinating works both ways and then
people were going to all sorts of places
touching and feeling it and then buying
it on the phone right on Amazon like
literally in the Best Buy's guy's face
yeah got an out literally an hour he'd
tell you everything and the person would
be like oh thank you
well they're drinking sorry no it's so
different because we're so different
like this I need no information on the
same way I like I guess that's it I know
I like this great she wanted to buy bike
for the kid like it was an awesome bike
and then she went through the whole
thing did it uh she went to go buy it
she's like why is it 200
ship it it's fruit journey he's on
lockdown the fact that I'm like but it
was honestly creatives I read it I am
one creatives I was just like those
details are boring it's why I can't ever
put anything together it's not that I'm
not handy it said I'm not gonna [ __ ]
read a manual [ __ ] that yeah basically
incapable of doing it [ __ ] so what are
you what do you see
let's take it again outside of your
world for a second as to people that are
in culture in business paying attention
what are you seeing overall in the
e-commerce business would there's a ton
of entrepreneurs here what should they
be seeing thinking about anything that
is catching your eye it's funny you know
the one thing I have been hearing which
you've probably heard as well beauty's
crushing it I'm crushing it and you know
listen that's because by the way part of
the reason that the beauty industry
don't flow well in general it's because
without sides it's without having to try
it on you like the shade of lipstick all
right I'm gonna buy it again you're at
home now you have time for self-care
you've never done a body scrub in your
life but guess what you have to do it
now there's also happiness yes of course
you know lipstick was a dominant item
during the Great Depression so there's a
lot of people right now with this
situation not feeling great and I'm not
a little bit of you know makeup or lime
and proper or scrubbing the [ __ ] out of
your face and it brings a lot of
happiness let me tell you something I
you know if I don't have an external
call like right now because I'm seeing
you like I have a little more makeup on
the normal but on a daily concealer
mascara and a lip done even if I'm
seeing nobody
like that's it mean you have to as a as
a woman so many of us just need to feel
human doesn't matter if a mess you know
for this question I'm a huge thesis
what is it thought on male makeup cuz I
hate your radar yet yeah listen well we
invested in it yeah we invested in a
male skin skink that's getting romantic
not skincare [ __ ] makeup yeah okay so
here's the thing I think
that our world has changed so much in
the last even two years three years um I
have seen more men in my life wearing
makeup and very proudly posting it on
social and women buying it from that men
buying it from that you know
yeah and for everybody's watching I'm
talking about straight male you know
like I think there's a real interesting
thing brewing if you look at tick tock
kind of these boys like the boys at the
14 year olds love like they look
different than the jock from through the
high school football team that people I
can probably share with you when I first
met Roger mm-hmm there might have been a
little black eyeliner in the waterline
and his morosini kind of yeah project
Raj has Raj has flavor come on I grew up
in the eighties but but you know I think
I think I'm all for it I think right now
especially honestly whatever makes you
feel like the last self more than ever
everyone needs confidence honestly I
know it's like coming out of this even
more so and what I worry more about is I
worry about the kids and the teens and
like so I think listen if guys want to
wear makeup like because oh by the way
the cat's like this is what I do for a
living like it's happened already gone
conclusion and I think I think it's
gonna be more extreme than people
realize that'll be fun to look back in
this video in 20 years where it's just
super normalized I want to remind a lot
of people I'm reading the comments no
way no way people people didn't work out
30 years ago yeah like like just to save
everybody time like people didn't work
out America didn't drink premium coffee
like weed like everybody in the world in
the 1980s made fun of America with
coffee because we drank [ __ ] coffee
out of like a white cup like friends
changed heavy yes mean yeah yes it is
freer than ever so I think like to each
his own
I don't think you saw men getting like
Botox and filler and manicures like
right now you're not embarrassed to say
you're getting a manicure as a guy like
oh my god you never thrust implants guys
are gonna have like literally Peck and
plant like did you do anything don't do
everything it's just gonna happen just
look at this thing my breast implants
like just for Hollywood 30 years ago now
like teenage girls sweet 16 like if
you're a high net-worth area like it's
just like things just change yeah things
become more acceptable over time and it
also depends on who's leading that
charge and who the example is that
people are following that's exactly
right
women's shapes embodies and men like
what what is considered cool that always
above's
and and and it's great and it's what's
so creative about the universe and and
it leads me to my point of like
e-commerce everyone's talking about post
koban explosion e-commerce I actually
think curb side pick up buy stores is
gonna become a monster 100% yes you know
I think that ya know the restaurants
obviously you know I think the
restaurants that are fortunate enough to
be able to do takeout service right now
I don't know how it is in New York but
in LA like all the major restaurants are
still doing to make out and marketing
themselves like crazy to just survive
you know and a lot of them becoming
which I'm sure you see and I don't know
if they're doing this in New York but
here a lot of the restaurants are
becoming and by the way places like
tender greens and sweet meats are
becoming market places like vegetable
baskets and things and like stock up and
like milk it's it's really it's been
very impressive to me to watch the
e-commerce businesses especially it's
been the younger ones be shown imbel and
literally turn their business today
almost overnight when you have no choice
you out of a should always comes from
these times correct and that's what I
was gonna say I believe to be the
positive and I think what's happening
for better for worse is a lot of
businesses you know that needed to make
major decisions but we're like during
over it this is definitely for Stan oh
yeah where
ya know nobody's sitting on conveniences
are nice-to-haves anymore I think this
accelerated everything to three years
and I do you know the thing the thing
about it is I I do believe that sort of
pick up in that and the like listen we
live in LA valet parking is like what
we're all used to you know people come
here like oh my god this is amazing
yeah it's called valet parking so the
same thing could happen for your
products the big problem is everyone's
over stored and if you're gonna do a
pickup thing you're not doing it in like
a real estate you know with 3000 square
feet that's the issue so the footprints
wrong for that unfortunately in my
opinion and that's where that's where
the that's where it's a little different
but yeah but what's funny is it's what's
funny and I obviously let's talk about a
Rodeo Drive just for ease like yes comma
I think that very high-end store gets a
call from you and say hey I just want to
pick this up there's gonna be so much
friction on the other side to do that
they're like no just come in or you can
go calm and I'm curious than even in
that scenario will their just be the
mindset of like yeah okay cuz like all
of a sudden it just becomes a norm I
mean when I was what when I launched my
calm every I was telling my dad's liquor
store friends you should do this too and
the answer was no no why would I be up
side that's a bad I remembered you mer
Roger like everything was gonna be a bad
course it's crazy
my dad has never bought anything online
my dad is 800 and did he orbit his time
or no but he's now I mean if I direct
them I have to buy things for my mom on
Amazon and that's only because my dad
won't let her have an account because
she'll never stop they'll be like
thousands of them some boxes a day so
then she calls me and asked me to order
and then I love but I mean Appletree
right so so you know I think I think the
thing is is I don't think it's a fad I
think that look let's be very realistic
about this until there's a vaccine there
are gonna be ads inflows of what this
looks like the norm is gonna be very
different for a while
and I think that measures are gonna
happen I think I think the big problem I
think is these big footprints that
people have and they will most
definitely unless we serious most of
them were not full before this happened
because I actually would argue that
target and others might be saved by this
because they were going through an
inevitable death and instead now they're
innovating and they may fight you know
they have a great situation for curbside
pickup yeah nothing but parking right
about curbside like what I don't really
get I get the curbside thing but if you
really take it a step forward how much
do you let this talk about step forward
first for food I get it mm-hmm I think
for hard goods and even soft goods I
think it's I think it's an issue because
if you really think about it why go to a
strip center to park your car to walk to
go get a bag to go bring it back in your
car and to go bring it home you might
wonder why would they have to grab the
bag why can't it be put right in your
trunk while you're aligning it shows up
at my doorstep because you'll appreciate
this it's a great I'm with you but it's
called convenience right so for example
if you happen to work five days a week
in this in a place where you drive by a
Walmart and you are like for example the
Amazon that's the boxes are through the
roof right so you got a hunt you got
hundreds of thousands of people in
America who are super frustrated because
their stuff is getting stolen while work
mmhmm yeah number two there you know
there's a lot of things that need to be
signed for and nobody's home and again
it's just driving patterns like it only
takes you an extra six minutes to get
off the highway go into the shopping
center it's put in your car you're on
your phone the whole time in the road
you know like there will be people that
it will work for by the way my parents
would always stop to go pick it up yeah
I'm the there's always that I I'm
talking about literally it's more
convenient literally it's more commute
there's AA give me one some people don't
want to open the box I mean dead serious
right now there are actually people who
would prefer to spend three and a half X
simply call it seven minutes to go in
because I do think the retailers will
get efficient with it you'll be on your
app don't know you're there all that
rather have it in the back
I then have to come home and open up all
those cardboard boxes like there's
really that it's gonna be interesting to
see what happens I think like all thing
I think that's a really good point I
think that's a really good point I think
like all things it's been a change but
cable TV's still around pretty strong so
here no but I'm saying like I always
have those visions of like wait hey I I
remember like wait we're gonna be
looking and like going on vacation and
like I'm with you on that but don't
forget Amazon is Amazon Prince two days
you know so I'm driving home so every
same day no minutes delivery I get it
I mean I'm what I'm saying is I'm with
you by the way
I fully think that people think things
are gonna happen too soon yeah I
actually think it's gonna be binary if
you can if there's a good curbside
service from Best Buy and you know it's
true and it cost you an extra 11 minutes
you may pick that versus what you would
have bought on Amazon but if it's not
then you're gonna buy it on Amazon
Amazon is gonna do last mile
everything's gonna change I mean there's
consent there's kitchens being built
underground you know it's already in LA
there's tons of restaurants that don't
have a footprint there because I don't
consider yeah whatever yeah um totally
agree
we're gonna be living in the Jetsons you
know no no it's gonna be uh my favorite
cartoon of all time yeah the Jetsons
present well Delroy no no are you
kidding I love beauty and Jane like ever
and all I ever dreamed of was that I
lived in outer space and then I got
there and like you know there was like a
conveyor of things it was like her
closet and then it just put the clothes
huh there's the maids name again oh he's
a robot
it was wait am I waiting wait wait a
minute
his boy Elroy wait I remember the song
now dude yes Dustin you're on mute
Dustin thanks for trying to come in and
ruin our show but it's Rosie I just
yeah I knew oh that would have literally
killed me all day well register there is
Google you could have looked it up yep
listen here's the thing Roger has this
thing and so do i and the only people we
excuse are my parents but like it's
almost like you can't ask anymore you
can't it's unacceptable it's
unacceptable to say how old is Julie
answered my entire [ __ ] life when I'm
putting out content especially when it's
live it's like Gary Vee
everything's so high level like okay
give me the talk the tactic I'm like
[ __ ] google it or go on YouTube
and saying how do I post an ad on like
then enter the [ __ ] do you want me to
talk about the most commoditize thing in
the world
which is [ __ ] information yes if
someone asks me where a restaurant is I
respond use the Google machine it's
crazy and then I say don't say it's my
anyway yes I hear you
it's just intellectual laziness that's
the most my most important that's my
what's your best tips for the
entrepreneurs to start or to grow a
ecommerce business from your perspective
today okay so mine would be and what I
always say is you have to have something
to say that is vastly different from
what's already out there what's the
point of view because I use that
question to myself and my team about
every single thing that we make or sell
like ok so if I want to start making
casual wear and basics or swimwear and
some of these other partnerships that
I'm working on why why why are they
buying this from me
when I look at it and it's this great
black dress why why aren't they buying
this and the other 50 choices that they
have that may even be less expensive
than this why and I think that you're
launching an e-commerce business no
matter what it is fashion food anything
because I get asked this from friends
all the time you know do you have to
have a point of differentiation because
almost everything exists right so it's
like either points
not really doesn't or that's much harder
it's almost like your personality in a
way
this greet she's a great chef looking
from catering she's bored at home she's
mom like whatever I'm like you have to
use your skill she's like but right now
I'm cooking for five people and I'm just
making like old school almost like Julia
Child's stuff in a big pot I go then do
that because no one else is doing that
right now
everyone's doing wellness health gluten
free dairy free this free go with that
there's so many people left in this
world in this country that want that
because that's real oh all I want to do
is sell like high sugar snacks
yeah the market is awesome mm-hmm so I
think for me that's my biggest advice is
you have to take something you're super
passionate about you have to believe in
it because if you don't you cannot sell
it and really just choose that and run
with it and I would say this the second
big piece of advice is go narrow and
deep yeah go narrow and deep and you'll
see the real successful companies that I
think that are building brands that are
gonna be around for more than a minute
they start with one product or two
products they get it well and they go to
the next product that I carry you build
on because what are some of your
favorite products excuse me we obviously
got the boxer's what are some of your
favorite products
forget about econ just macro things
you're addicted to drinks food cereal
clothing brand like little your favorite
brands right now right or or
historically have been I mean my my
favorite I love eight there I don't know
if you know ether apparel there might go
you for like oh my cuz I like skiing and
not outdoor wet and I'm not like
outdoorsy but I love skiing so deep now
I love doing that I love like API like
artist API like all the sneakers from
them artist propulsion labs
what about cereal okay so I was gonna
comment on that he doesn't know because
he's never bought one piece of food for
this entire house he actually doesn't
know the answer to that besides
Kellogg's
but this there's this company that I'm
completely obsessed with that I buy at
it's 12 at a time called love grown have
you heard of it I don't think so yes yes
you know but this is but I'm like him I
might hold on I probably know this brand
extremely well
oh yeah I know this one it's it's me the
reason I love it is not clean and
organic and all that because I love a
nice brand um but I love it because they
make they're like the first people to
make amazing organic good job cucumber
well done Bob I'm versions of what we
grew up with as sugar cereals that we
were only allowed to have on weekends
they make with like chickpeas and
lentils and all that my kids literally
video kelp noodles or yes of course holy
[ __ ] that's a game changer for me yeah
it's like a miracle noodle like Roger
loves those it's like carb-less yes I
completely completely changed my game
cuz I look like that is like a go to
like I'm gonna [ __ ] up right now and eat
pasta like love it ROG I just brought up
kelp noodles you're a big fan too you
know I've gone down the road and you
know what it is this is a thing it's a
slippery slope I've been so off the real
stuff for so long has been gradually
moving down the slippery slope that if
you give me something that's like
resembles a low-carb pasta I may be the
world cauliflower cost to join Passover
I thought he was gonna spit it out he
actually is a great help
it's quick it's crazy to me how good it
is all right that's like it's like it's
like one calorie it's an absurd let's do
it I love that stuff I love the vegan
sausage and all that good stuff
what about what about what else so I
like the cereals what this is that's a
really fun for me cereals I love all the
companies that oh oh oh oh obsessed
simple Mills amazing brand what does
that put on anything again like organic
almond flour based products they do
everything from it's all gluten-free and
very you can do amazing baking with your
kids
pancakes Belgian waffles all that love
and the kids love it and I know that
it's good because my kids are not like
fools like that you can't like they know
if it tastes like dirt what about
alcohol
you guys drink wine beer liquor I'm only
wine he's what ever has alcohol in it
and so what about in that world any
brands that dominate marine I believe we
just have we just invested in the
organic wine company called aveline
Cameron Diaz and Kathryn power well they
started an organic wine company which by
the way not that's fish are we breaking
news here breaking news I'm not sure I
don't know well I mean the reason
they're racist theories a I can't
imagine the pain I worry about this
organic wine D to see and I have to say
the products amazing into organic wine
right now I actually believe that I wake
up not feeling crappy when I drink and I
don't drink a lot but I would say that I
feel different when I drink I think
organic alcohol is gonna be a big break
what do you mean do you think mocktails
are gonna be big like literally $20
cocktails that don't have alcohol in
them that's that seems crazy to me it's
it's a very interesting underlining
trend right now no no it's definitely a
trend any luck I live in LA there's a
lot of fun feeling limited friends in LA
there's a lot of people thank you it's
also true friends of business makes you
know what I mean like even those like
again I don't want to say anything bad
but like those Milka thing like those
like those there's everywhere like how
there's nothing wrong with your opinions
on whether you know there's nothing
wrong with like like like people dis on
soda I love a good soda with a lemon in
line yes but I haven't had anything with
a spur team in I mean at least 10 years
you know I flavor their sodas now with
stevia or nuts if Diet Coke would use
stevia that would be a game-changer but
anyway I'm a big fan of sangre Tianjin
if you must know I'm a big fan of
Bulleit Bourbon
this is my basic you know I really need
to answer this question the way I'd like
answer so Gary Roger I'm sitting down
for dinner yes I'll start off with its
hangry ten martini that's a good
starting point that gets you settled it
there's nothing like a big glass of gin
to get the night dog very and then which
I allowed two nights a week at home and
then from there I'm a civilized human
being so I obviously have wine during
dinner and then if there are a sign of
wine
normally historically I know you have
vested interest now in your homies no
I'm kidding choice would always be a
Sancerre okay first choice yeah some
you'll belong from the Loire Valley of
France yes I like a good sense they're
very dry Chablis I love Muscadet
sometimes you're very French girl you
know you're doing very heavy French
French for sure yeah and also Rose a
same thing from Provence you know what
about you Raj are you do drink Reds
well if when I do drink red she doesn't
so I also have a crazy thing this is
actually good to share with the audience
some people think that they're allergic
to show yeah this is perfect you're
gonna love this one
some people think they're allergic to
shellfish people think they're that
they're allergic to red wine what
they're actually allergic to is when
they drink red wine with shellfish
because the sulfites in the red wine and
the iodine in this in the shellfish is a
bad reaction
for some people it's sort of like when
you with the cilantro tastes like salmon
it's a little like Swiss illogical yep I
didn't never realize that I could have
shellfish all I want I got red wine all
I want if I have like you with clam your
dead dad soloing up all over Rachel's
faith yes it takes like six hours oh
yeah but it's really great can I tell
you one more brand that I really love
yes I'm color fiha farms you know it
they say calathea or calathea it's not
almond milk coffee you see you're gonna
know what I'm talking about yeah it is
an incredible incredible
Brown we have switched to like yes I
know it's super I have literally in my
fridge or in right now
but yeah you know what's so funny about
this yeah yeah this is what's so
interesting about brand right you know
this you would do you have the Bravo
platform your social like like like
people come up to me like hey Garvey
love your stuff on on Instagram because
the way they see it on Instagram they
think it's not Gary Vee it's Garvey like
like to build it actual brand take so
long you literally just mentioned a
brand I said I don't know it I then
googled it while we were talking it's
literally in my fridge and I love the
oat milk YUM
yeah it's great and you know what else
is great if you're a god you're there
they make espresso shots with almond
milk already ready for you you know like
the Starbucks wasn't only for you know I
nobody meant I actually think it is good
for you like I actually don't want to
demonize a little escapism once in a
while right people go to extreme either
one way to the other like once in a blue
moon mixing it up I think is helpful or
every night drinking well that's
different
alright last minute what do you guys
have to say Wow last minute I'm gonna
give a plug for Vayner commerce I don't
know if you know of a recent client we
work with Gary we're clients buddy I
love it they're doing me happy I loves
the team and we're building some same
technology on Shopify so we're very big
Shopify people zero engineers in our
entire company not one and that's what
we're doing how about for you what's the
what's go Rach winner low-hanging genes
coming back for the ladies like that
like that Paris Hilton like look is that
coming back that was a look I'm not
gonna lie if I don't see butt cracks I'm
okay with that
no I bet era that era was really cool to
me I feel like I feel it in the air I
feel like it could come back I agree
with the pendulum and denim always
swings so that's why I believe it I
believe it's best about time
if you like one tick-tock er is gonna do
it and it's gonna be [ __ ] insanity
you know who needs to do it in order to
make it happen who you know Charlie no
if any if you're gonna run out of time
no all right listen
I think the audience probably knows that
if there's one certain family of people
that well yes of course it's something
on yes that would be the game changer
right that's right
I I actually like the high waist I feel
for you though I understand highways has
gotten too high right Roger agrees he's
not yeah what is so come on give me one
good little one because you're so
[ __ ] epic at this what's like super
on the cusp of merging like headbands or
[ __ ] like yes sir yeah she's the
[ __ ] best you don't have to guess cuz
guessing leads to B is there anything
that's actually you don't think I never
guess musically it was already happening
take like I know it because I can see
the very early indicators is there any
very early indicator of something is
starting to brew yeah I mean I know how
about tie-dyed tight ice here I mean
it's here in a really really big way
really really I still don't think a lot
of people know that so that's one oh
okay well that's definitely like two in
yep they're like on in yourself to give
your answer sorry right you're thinking
you just want a fashion trend
listen um asks do you think masculine to
be super we we are announcing ours today
our mass fortune and also I think masks
yes are the news cheek for sure and I
think every iteration of things that are
gonna be this I think we're gonna start
seeing shirts with things you can pull
up but I think I like that enacting yeah
oh that's clever and longer sleeves to
cover your hands with finger holes I
think that I'm back in a big way because
of all of this but I think listen I
think we can make safety incredibly
thick and fashionable I think that's our
job as creative people to still somehow
keep people sheet during a pandemic I
agree thanks for being on guys you were
great yeah talk to you soon there in
real life at some point soon I'll talk
to Zhu Ben to them yeah the real